Codex's browser use is probably the best
that I've ever tried before. It can
literally do anything on a browser or on
your actual local computer. And if you
need to be signed in for something, you
just sign in once and Codex will save
it. So, the possibilities are endless.
You can actually automate anything now.
Let me show you guys how to set it up,
how easy it is, and a few good use
cases. All right. So, I'm using the
Codex desktop app, which is just
honestly the main way that I like to
drive Codex. It's super, super slick.
And we get the browser to pop up on the
right-hand side, which I'll show you
guys in a sec. So, luckily we live in a
world now where most tools that we need
to use have an API guy. So, it's much
easier to just connect Codex through the
API. Or, if we just go to the plugins,
there's hundreds of plugins in here.
But, every once in a while we don't have
an API, and you can do that with browser
use. But, before I show you an
automation like that, let's just take a
look at this example where you might be
building a website. You might be
building some sort of app. And you need
a browser, an agent, to actually test
through things. If you guys watched a
recent video I did on like building an
AI SaaS in one day, then this was
actually from that demo where I had a
browser agent get spun up and test the
heck out of our app. And it did 85
focused auto- mation checks with real
browser workflow testing, which means it
was clicking around, it was typing
things, it was hitting buttons, and it
was trying to break the app. And it
found a ton of bugs, and then we were
able to just fix them. So, in this
example, I have a super simple website
spun up here on the localhost. It's a
form submission, as you can see. And
there's a few issues before we actually
go ahead and start testing this thing.
You can see like this spacing is weird.
This thing is overlapping. And so, what
you can do is you can click on this
annotate button, and that lets you
choose very specific elements to
actually change. So, I can click right
here on this phone number box, and I can
describe, "Hey, this is kind of like
overlapping. It's out of bounds. It's
covering up the company box. So, I need
you to fix this." And then, when you
shoot that off, it actually goes over
here into your chat. And then, you can
make another annotation like, "Okay. So,
this whole box isn't really aligned on
the same Y axis as number one and number
three. So, you need to fix that as
well." And then, those annotations are
saved over here, and we can just go
ahead and shoot them off. So, that's
kind of like a lovable style or like a
cloud design style thing that you can do
with the in-app browser in Codex. What
else is really cool about this is that
you can actually just drive this thing.
So, you can go to Google, you can search
for Grand Canyon images, you can go to
all, you can go to different links if
you want. You can use the browser right
here while you have Codex open. But, of
course, Codex can also just take control
of it. Now, we can see right here is my
mouse, but also this is what Codex's
mouse looks like. And that's how you
know it's now sort of getting ready to
take control of the browser. Okay, so
now that those changes have been made,
let's actually start testing out our UI.
I want to see things that maybe me as a
human, I would maybe go through here and
test like five or six edge cases, but we
can see how Codex can do it way quicker
and way more. Okay, so you have the UI
open. I want to make sure that there are
no bugs. I want to make sure that this
thing can't break. So, what I want you
to do is use your browser use and just
test the heck out of this thing. Try
different things, try your best to break
it, and let me know what bugs you find
and what things we need to fix. And so,
by the way, while this is running,
there's a difference between browser use
being headless or headed. Headless means
it's running in the background, so you
can keep working in the foreground, and
you won't actually see it going on, but
it can run a lot of things in the
background. But, if you want it to be
headed, that's basically where you're
able to see it. So, we're probably going
to be able to see some things right
here, but if you wanted this to just
work for a few hours for you headless in
the background, you could ask it to do
so, and then it wouldn't disturb
whatever work you're doing. So, if you
ever hear that terminology, that's what
it means. So, there you go. You can see
that the mouse is moving around right
now. It tried to click continue, and
then it says first name is required,
enter a valid email address, and enter a
10-digit phone number.
And now you can see it just entered in
some information and it was able to hit
continue. And it's just going to keep
going through this QA check. We're
validating that some of these fields are
required options and that the continue
button won't actually let it move on
without
filling those in. And by the way, the
reason you're seeing some of these UI
bugs is because I asked this chat to
like make there be a few UI things to
fix because I wanted to show you guys
the annotations. So, just ignore that.
Mainly, what I'm trying to show you guys
now is the actual browser use QA
function. So, here you can see as it's
clicking around, as it's trying to
navigate this UI, it already said the
core click path mostly works, but I've
confirmed two real data integrity
problems already, which is that
obviously invalid contact data does get
through, and changing the country code
to UK resets to US when you return to
edit. I'm now testing keyboard
submission and restart behavior, which
often exposes bypasses the click path
misses. So, think about it like this, no
matter what you get, you're going to
want to test it, but would you rather
have something that has been not tested
at all, or would you rather have
something that has been tested 100 times
already by an AI agent? Especially if
you tell the agent to try to break it,
it's going to find some things that need
to be fixed. No matter how good you are
at trying to predict edge cases, when
you push an app into production and
users start using it, people are weird,
people are unpredictable, so they're
going to do things. And so, this agent
is able to hopefully simulate weird
humans and just find things that you
might not have thought of. You can see
here, it even switched this to mobile
view to still make sure that
everything's working. And look at this,
in mobile it found a few failures in
responsiveness. So, that isn't something
that I yet had tested. Okay, so this
thing finished up now, and you can see
that we have a bunch of things that
passed, but a bunch of things that also
failed. So, it was able to find all of
these bugs because it was testing the
UI, and it didn't even do it that long.
If we wanted to make this even harder,
we could do a slash goal, and we could
say, "Hey, don't stop until you've tried
100 different unique scenarios of, you
know, UI edge cases, and then come back
to me." But, it still found a lot of
things that were broken, and now all
we'd have to do is say, "Okay, cool, go
implement those changes. Go fix all
those bugs." Okay, so let me show you
guys another example. This is when you
maybe have some sort of platform where
you want to be able to like download
statements or something, but they don't
have an API. So, you can actually
interact with it with Codex's browser
use because it basically uses vision and
then AI to analyze like what it's
looking at and where to click. And I
would I just want to show you how easy
it actually is to build these. All I
said was, "Hey, you know, I want to
build the skill, blah blah blah, what
would be helpful?" And you could record
a quick Loom, you could send screenshots
with arrows, but you actually don't have
to. You can basically just describe
pretty clearly what you need to do. So,
what happened here is it opened up
Relay, I signed in, and it saved that
session. Now, I said, "Okay, in the
Relay dashboard, you're signed in. What
I need you to do is go to the dashboard,
click on accounts, find the statements,
um, click on these two accounts,
download them as CSVs, and then put them
into this folder. And it was able to do
that on one shot. I didn't have to give
it any feedback, and it downloaded them
and saved that whole flow as a skill.
Now, this is super helpful because now I
could, at the end of the month, just set
this up as a scheduled routine because I
could set a scheduled routine here and
say, "Hey, use this skill on the most
recent, you know, month statement in
Relay." And for the most part, Codex is
going to save your sessions when you're
logged in. However, there are some
limitations like the fact that Relay is
going to pretty much boot you out
because it's, you know, it's a banking
platform. It's going to be secure and
boot you out. So, look at this here. I
asked it to do this again, and it said,
"Hey, Relay is open at the login screen,
but you have to sign in again." Now,
what's really interesting that you can
do is you can actually open up your
settings. You can have a password
manager inside of Codex. And you can see
this goes to your browser, and now you
can go to import them so that Codex can
actually fill that out for you. And that
way you're not putting it into the chat
history or anything like that. You're
saving it more securely. So, all you
have to do for that is create a CSV file
that looks like this. I've got the name,
the URL, the username, the password, and
any notes, which in this case are empty.
I imported that here, right here as a
file, a CSV file, and now we have
relay.com password. Go ahead and try
this again in the password manager for
the in-app Codex browser. You should be
able to log in now. And then run the
skill on June. All right, so over here
now you can see the browser has taken
control, and it is going to put in my
email and my password. Now, if this asks
me for a two-factor authentication code
from my phone or something, then I'm
obviously not going to be able to do
that. I'd have to do that manually. But
hey, if I was on a Mac and my text went
there and I used computer use to do
that, technically you would be able to
automate that whole thing, but I would
say you probably want to be careful
about stuff like that. But as you can
see, it was able to pull the passwords
from my password manager, paste those
in, and now it should be able to log in
to Relay for me. You can see here that
the mouse has moved over to accounts.
It's then going over to statements, and
it's going to be able to download these
two statements for us. So, you can see
it's pretty cool that it was able to
figure all this out. Remember, I've only
ran this skill once and all I did was
instruct it with natural language to do
this. Now, realistically, is that the
way you should do it, especially with
something like a bank account? No. What
you should do is
have it do the skill, you sit here and
watch it, and have it do that like
at least 10 times where you're very
closely watching it to make sure nothing
goes wrong, and you're making sure the
script in the skill is super strict.
Because at the end of the day, it's
using vision, it's using AI, and that's
how it's deciding what to click and what
to do. So, really the way that I think
about it is when you want to automate
something, your first call should always
be to go for an API. Like, that's what
you want to do. It's the fastest, it's
usually the cheapest, it's usually just
the most consistent. Now, if there's no
API, that's where you would maybe say,
"Okay, cool. Well, now let me see if I
could use like a deterministic, you
know, like a macro script, right?" And
that's where you'd basically be able to
have, yes, you know, it'd be more of a
browser use because you have a mouse
that's clicking around, but it's not
like your mouse needs reasoning. Your
mouse doesn't need to look at the
screen, figure out where to click, and
based on the next UI that pops up, where
do I click again? This is basically more
like, "Okay,
I have to click on this pixel, then this
pixel, then this pixel every single
time." That's something that you could
do for much cheaper and much safer by
just programming a macro. And that's not
that hard either. You just ask Claude or
Codex, "Hey, help me figure out how to
make like a deterministic macro script
to just click on these pixels in that
order every single time." But, if you
can't do that every single time because
there is an element of vision or
reasoning, then you need to come in here
and you need to do something like some
browser use. And luckily, Codex has your
back. I've tested a lot of different
apps and different CLIs and different
things for browser use, and so far Codex
is just really solid. So, as you can see
now, in my downloads, this is the
statements that it just downloaded as a
zip file, and it basically took these
and it put it into my Hercule project.
If I go in here and I scroll down to
statements, and I go to probably June,
yes, June, you can see right here it put
those in here in the correct spot. Okay,
so that was an example where we needed
to save a password somewhere, right? But
I've done this with things like school,
I've done this with things like X, I've
even done this with things like
Instagram that don't make you constantly
resign in because it saves that session.
So let me show you another example. I'm
going to go over here to YouTube and I'm
going to grab the URL from the video
that I uploaded earlier today. I'm going
to go back into Codex, paste in that URL
and say,
"I need you to turn this YouTube video
into an X article for me and then use
browser use to go ahead and um format it
and put it into an X article as a draft
and then I will go ahead and review it."
So I know some of you guys are probably
thinking, "Why don't you just use X's
API for that?" You can, but it's a
little bit weird with the formatting.
It's also weird with sometimes adding
things like media or thumbnails for some
reason, at least with my testing that I
used to do, and it's also it charges
you, right? Because you have to pay X
per usage in order to do something like
that. And so because this is just part
of my Codex subscription, I can just run
this skill and it will go ahead and
format everything for me and take care
of it. I even have the skill worked out
where it can go ahead and open up my
YouTube videos and it can take
screenshots of specific moments and put
those into the article, too, where it
makes sense. So obviously this is a bit
of a loaded process because it has to do
a few steps before it actually has the
article ready to put into X. So while
that's happening, let's just open up a
new chat and let's see if our X session
is there.
"Can you open up a browser? I want to
see it right here in the app and just go
to X and scroll around a little bit and
show me if there's anything new that has
just come out um like in the AI space.
Just scroll on my X feed." And so
because this was a brand new session, we
can actually see if X is already signed
in and if it's able to interact with
things.
Cool. So it just opened up X. Let me get
my mouse out of here. You can see
clearly that this is already signed in
as me and my feed is visible and now it
is going ahead and it's starting to
scroll on the X page. So just start to
think about already, how could you
create some sort of skills out of this
and then schedule these as tasks? So,
maybe every morning if you wanted it to
scroll through Instagram and things like
that, or scroll through your own
profile, or mark things as read or
unread, you could totally go ahead and
do that, no problem, because you can set
up the schedule tasks right in here and
use browser use skills that you've
already set up. So, you can see the two
things that it already noticed was Grok
Bot and Grok 4.6. So, this is an
interesting case though, because there
is an API, but using the browser use is
actually cheaper. So, that's why in this
case we decided to do it and test it
out. Now, what about computer use that
you guys have also probably heard? These
are basically the same thing. It's still
going to use vision. It's still going to
use AI, but the difference here is that
the browser is basically things that are
on the internet, or things that you
would type into a browser like Chrome,
but the computer use are things that
might be on your actual computer. So,
changing your computer settings, opening
up desktop apps of things. So, let's go
back into Codex. While we're waiting for
this X article to finish up, let's see
how this is going. It is still breaking
down and turning it into an article.
Let's see if we can do some computer
use. So, one thing you have to do though
is you have to go to plugins, and you'll
have to actually install computer use,
which is just as simple as typing in
computer use and hitting install, like
literally 2 seconds. And then,
Hey Codex, I need you to use computer
use to open up my desktop app for Glydo,
and I just want you to go to the
settings and turn on the ability for it
to allow and use like Bluetooth devices.
So, just go ahead and get that set up
for me. And so, this is a little bit
different, right? Because it's not going
to open up your in-app browser. It's
going to actually kind of show your
screen being taken over. It said, "I'll
stop if Windows asks for an admin
password or presents a security
sensitive permission that it can't
safely interpret." It shouldn't run into
any of that, but it's good that it sort
of has that guardrail baked in.
Interesting. Okay, so it said,
"Bluetooth access is a privacy
permission, so the computer use won't
let me actually do that." But, what it
said it's going to do is open up Glydo.
As you can see, I didn't open that up.
It opened up Glydo for me. And it
doesn't look like on my recording you
guys can actually see this right now,
but my screen kind of has like a big
blue hue around the edges. So, you will
clearly know if Codex is using your
computer.
And there you go. You can see that it
actually turned on the include Bluetooth
devices button. Now, I think it got
confused because I think at first it
thought that I was messing with my
actual computer settings rather than
like an in-app setting. So, it thought
that that was a security thing. But, it
looks like it figured that out on the
way. And I think the computer use thing
is pretty interesting because you can
remote into your Codex from your phone.
So, I can control all of these sessions
on my phone. And what I could do is on
my phone I could say, "Hey, computer
use, go ahead and change my settings or
go ahead and do something on a desktop
app that's on my PC that I'm actually
not sitting in front of." And then you
could control your computer from your
phone. So, anyways, we're back in the
session where it's creating that X
article. You can see that it is actually
creating some thumbnails for the actual
article. So, hopefully we're getting
close to the point where it's going to
actually open up X and start to put
stuff in there. But, I'll check with you
guys when we get there. Okay, so it just
decided to open up X. You can see that
it's going to the drafts in my signed in
X and then it's going to I'll go ahead
and format this new article and then
we'll take a look. It's clicking on the
plus button. Man, I think it even just
like resized the page a little bit. It
was getting a little picky. In goes the
title. And then it just pasted in the
entire content of the article. Now, it's
uploading this thumbnail which I don't
think looks very good. That part of the
skill has not been refined at all. But,
it's still cool that it was able to make
that thumbnail and then go ahead and put
it in there. So, I literally just have
to make sure that it looks okay and I
like it and I can publish it. Now, I
know what a lot of you guys are probably
thinking when it comes to this browser
use stuff. It's like,
"What's the point, Nate? Like, where's
the value?" And honestly, I understand
where you're coming from. And that's why
I wanted to show you guys this piece
where it's like
pretty much API will handle 95% of your
automation things that you need. And
then a lot of the browser use
opportunities might just be a script.
But, then when you need it, if you have
this in your back pocket, it's good. And
you also might think, "Okay, cool. But,
like, how much time does this really
save?" This probably saves me like maybe
5 to 10 minutes. Like, realistically.
But, what's cool about it is that I can
basically have this pipeline now where I
have a bunch of these browser use
skills, and so when I need to do
something, I just open up Codex, I shoot
off that skill, and I can go back to the
other task that I was working on. It
kind of just like helps you do more
without context switching as much. And
as you start to stack more and more of
these pipelines and combine them
together, you can get some really cool
things to happen when you start to chain
together these skills. And look, this
one actually did it. It basically did
the thing where I said it opened up the
YouTube video, it took screenshots of
it, and now it's going ahead and it's
planting some screenshots from my video
in the article. So, if that doesn't
prove the capabilities of this thing
being intelligent, take screenshots,
look at the page, know where to click,
know what to do, then I don't know what
else will. Besides the fact that I've
had this thing play chess, I've had it
play games, I've had it set a world
record on Tetris, it can do a lot of
cool things.
Look at this. You can see that it even
took the image and drug it all the way
down to where it actually fits in the
article. I haven't actually seen it do
that before live. That was pretty cool.
And this thing is just still going at
it. But that is going to do it for
today's video. Hope you guys enjoyed it.
Hope you learned something new, and if
you did, please give it a like. It helps
me out a ton. As always, I appreciate
you guys making it to the end of the
video, and I'll see you on the next one.
Thanks, everyone.